how does a relatively tiny spider make a
meal of a relatively large bash first
the spider in this case an orb web
spider in southern Belize creates a
sticky trap directly in the flight path
of the victim the bat zooms right into
this web and then goes into shock what
happened one minute airborne the next
minute fighting for your life now the
spider examines its prey is there
gloating going on here is the spider
lording it over the bat herd just trying
to figure out which part to eat first
the spider spray silk from its
spinnerets ceiling the bats fate turn
out the lights the party's over
now the baddest cocoon and the spider
administers death by a thousand bites